Hey everybody, welcome! Do you love comedy? Do you love to laugh? We'll buckle up because you're gonna fucking cry your eyes out. Welcome to SmartLess. Hi everybody. Oh, Sean, what a nice top you have on this morning. Yeah. Oh, it's look what's it say? I can't read it. It says, it says SmartLess and that's Hayes 20. Hayes on the back. It's our, Hayes 20, what does it say 22 on the back? 26, 26. 26. That's our birth date, right? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Well, so it's a SmartLess shirt. You can guess we're gonna get the freaking merch plug right at the top. Yeah, right there. It's right there. I'm wearing it. It's good to know that it's good to know that we make
it in a double XL too. Yeah. Good for you. You know what I mean? It's good. You got both boobs stuck right in there. No. Bang, bang, pow, pow. How's everybody feeling? Is everybody a little sleepy today? Yeah, a little sleepy. It's a little early. I could feel that. I could feel that. I, last, yesterday, I saw I'm in Tech Week. Oh, well, this is probably gonna air after we open. Well, what's Tech Week for? What are you talking about? Are you doing a play in New York? Is he in New York? At the Tabasco? So, at the Tabasco Theater. It's so spicy this show, y'all. You gotta go check it out. It's stupid. Anyway, the Tabasco Theater, David Bellasco was the owner and this I just found out yesterday.
I couldn't wait to share it with you guys. Actually, last night, because we're working like 12, 14 hour days, whatever it is. Well, I don't know how many hours, but it's long hours. A lot of people work. Seems like you do know them. Yeah. And so this crew guy comes because everybody has these stories because there's an apartment on top of the theater now that what's that? Oh, the crew guy. I think so. Crew guy. Yeah. Crew guys. There's an apartment on top of the camera. I'm like, Oh, these guys got a screw guy. All right. What kind of? I'm like, screw guy, please. And they just send one over right away. He's in over the screw guy. So the screw guy gets there. Oh, speaking of which, Scotty, Scotty
got his cue. You want by just as I said, screw guy. Anyway, like, see Scotty go by just shuffle by it in short. Anyway. Okay. So there's crew guy told me about this story because it's supposed to be haunted and below sometimes. And so David Blasco, who owned the theater years and years and years ago, there's this apartment on top of the theater that's now abandoned and nothing's up there. But he used to live there and there was an elevator shaft where he used to bring up, you know, lady friends over and over, right? And so one of the ladies fell through the elevator shaft and died. It's now like boarded up. And people say, and they call her lady in blue because people say they can see her
in the seats sometimes. How do you fall through an elevator shaft? I guess it was open and there was no elevator. I guess. I don't know. Boy, there was an episode of LA law once. I'm not making it up where the guys, I swear to God, it was on the, I just saw a clip of it recently and they're having a conversation about the elevator door and this woman speaks really tersely to the guy. She's like, so you better watch out, blah, blah, blah. The elevator door is open. She walks into the elevator shaft and falls, punches to her death. And the guy was like, oh my God, it was on TV. And that writer's room is like, how are we going to, what are we going to do in this episode? How are we going to, where is it
open? And she just falls through just like the lady in blue. Yeah. Have you hit fuck it yet on this, on this play? So I mean, it, it, it's a long run, right? It's been taxing for Jason and both Jason and me, it's been a lot. Yeah. So, but you haven't even started performances yet. You've been, you've been whacking away at it for how long now? You've already done it in Chicago for months and months and months. Now because it's so good and was so well received, you take it to New York, to the, to the hot and spicy Tabasco, and you, you're in rehearsals right now. You haven't gotten to the point of like, it's enough.
Um, no, I mean, you, you, as a, as a, You're discovering new things about it every day, right? Yeah, you do kind of. The surprise guest just mentioned, just, just, uh, Yeah, this is the surprise guest just tried to end it. Jason said, this is really interesting. Interesting. So maybe we should just start. Uh, I, I think he, it's a he has got comments on this too. Should we get right to him? Let's get right to him.
I mean, by the way, should we mention the plays open now? Yeah. I guess the plays open now by the time we work at the, at the, at the Belasco. Wait, what's it called? What's the play called? Okay. And did I like it on opening night? You would love it. It's called good night, Oscar. Okay. There it is. All right. Good night. Is there a comment there? There is after night and good night. I didn't know is two words.
I thought it was one word. And if you find yourself at the theater, watch out for a gaping shaft. Oh boy. Um, wait, I love that. We got to put that on the Sean list. So you thought good night was one word. I did that. Didn't you think it was one word? Probably not. Just like good morning. Has good morning ever been one word?
You know what else listener? Hang on Sean. Listener, Sean was shocked to learn that, uh, uh, John F. Kennedy was not shot in Washington DC or shot in Dallas. Because it's, it's stunning to me. You know what else listener is stunning about Sean? He was really surprised that Beatles, the group, the band. No, I'm not the only one that thought that didn't know it meant beat on a drum. BEAT.
Sean, I'm just noticing you're in your place in New York right now. And you guys, you've been there for a month now, but you don't, in the last couple of years, you haven't spent a ton of time there. No. But in that back shelf there, did you guys go to knick knacks or us? Load up on the knick knacks? That's a real Chatsky Haven. Hey, knick knack patty whack.
Look at your spider fern too up there on his own little, nice though. And that's feeling real well. All right, quiet down. Here comes a respectable guest. All right, look at a fella. Listen, this fella doesn't do this, okay? He doesn't do it at all.
He's trying to keep quiet and do his work. And while I haven't asked him, my bet is, is that he's dreading this and that he's thrilled that a full six minutes and 15 seconds are already over without him having to talk. My job is to make this as painless and breezy as possible. And I need your help, man, because this is a Grammy award-winning artist from Puerto Rico. And he's got a black belt in karate. Okay?
What? Most folks, however, know him as one of the best actors of our generation. So please say hello to actually one of the kindest, warmest, friendliest, most humble fellas I know. Let's welcome Joaquin Phoenix. Oh my God. Come on. Wow.
There he is. There he is. Hi, everybody. Hi. Wait, you're in a trailer, aren't you? Are you in a trailer? Yeah, so I'm on set. Oh.
Oh, for the Joker 2. Yeah. So I'm listening to the Jenny. You guys are on Jenny Power right now. Exactly. Exactly. Oh, that's the genre. Now, so then this is your lunch hour?
No, we're actually shooting kind of splits. So, you know, we're going to start in a little bit. So I just came up a little early. The beat from Beatles, is that really for beat, like drums? See, you dick. Yeah. That's exactly right. That was the impression I had to do with the beat poets.
Oh. Oh, I didn't even think about that. But no, it has to do with the beat. I thought it was the buzz. Sean, real quick, because Joaquin mentioned it, tell Tracy what splits are. I have no idea. Oh, bless him.
Bless him. They don't do splits on Will and Grace. No, it's always sensible. The best hours in all of showbiz. Which is like, it is the best. Split's listener is when you start at noon and you end at midnight. As opposed to if you shoot full nights, you start when the sun goes down and you end when the sun comes up.
Splits is kind of a half day, half night shoot. Yeah, that's perfect. Yeah, that's perfect. Joaquin, I don't even know where to start, man. I don't know you at all. We've never met and I'm such a fan. You're honestly, it's just, yeah. And I guess we, let's do it kind of like how we always,
what I want to know was what was the first of all, because you've done so many amazing characters and so many great movies, but what was the first, your first memory, like your first job that you did? First job I did was a guest starring spot on a TV show called Seven Brides for Seven Brothers, which my brother River starred in. And they were shooting in Northern California. And I think just by default, I think just because it was easy to get somebody local,
me and my sister played the small part in the show. And I think that was probably my first like significant job. The one time I worked with River, were you, I think you were, were you not in it too? We did the thing about the Kennedys. We played, we played like young Kennedys. I barely remember, I forget what it's called. Anyway, it was like a movie of the week or something like that,
about Robert F. Kennedy and his times. Did you play one of the, because you were so small, you probably couldn't even talk then, or maybe just barely, because we were like, we were 10 or 11 or something like that. Weren't we? Yeah, so I was six or seven. No, I don't, I don't remember that. I vaguely do now that you mentioned it.
It's like out in Massachusetts. I think the very first thing I did was, was that spot and then, and then, and then so the, the, so the acting to you as I, we're not, I'm not going to hammer you with your, all your fricking method and all that stuff, because I know you hate talking about that as, as, as do most. I don't know what it is.
I know, exactly. It's just, well, that's what my people ask me. No, I like that. I guess my question is, when did you get a sense that, that this acting thing might be a really comfortable thing for you to do and not something that's going to be a lot of work, you know, that it's not going to be like hammering nails?
I wouldn't say that it's very comfortable, but I certainly don't, don't care about that. I mean, I'm not, not looking for something that's comfortable. I'm looking for a unique experience. Yeah, you get it though, right? But when you see like, like Joaquin, when you, when you see an actor talk about their process and we've all seen it and people get into it
and they want to like focus, first of all, I remember doing this thing once and somebody was asking it like about, so we were doing Bojack Horseman and I got kind of, I think I was kind of a dick, but they were like asking about the process. And I said, why is everybody so obsessed with how the sausage is made?
Why can't they just enjoy the sausage, right? Like it's not that interesting. And, but then I see like, like, you know, these actors who talk, they spend a lot of time and you see them in these interviews and they're talking about their process and stuff. And I'm kind of like, okay, man, like if you want, you want accolades for what you're doing
and you want us to applaud the way you did it, like it seems a little self-serving. You have to forgive like everybody when they're doing an interview. That's true. Because you're just like, it's impossible, virtually impossible not to be an asshole when you're doing an interview.
At least for me, it's my experience. I mean, everybody fucking sounds stupid. That's true. There's just not a good way to come across. And oftentimes, like a lot of those quotes are from like when you've flown to go to like a film festival in New York and you're jet lagged and you have like a hundred interviews
and you start off just going like, I'm not going to do any of that shit. And within 30 minutes, you're just like, whatever it takes, just get me the fuck out of here and say anything. So like, yes, I read quotes from the interviews and I go, what a twat. And I go, I've done so much worse.
So I always feel like you have to give people like... I think you're, I'm with you on that. And that's totally fair enough. And yeah, like the interview and or junkie process is one of the worst sort of that you feel your soul leaving your body and you think like every word you say, you're like, God, I hate myself so much
for what I just said. And you're trying to come up with different ways to answer the same freaking question. You end up backing into a dumb answer. I think that what I meant was more that there are people, it seems like they go out of their way to consistently talk about that. And you're like, okay, that's what I was referring to.
However, having said that. Yeah. I mean, maybe, I don't know. I always think like whatever it takes, whatever works for you, it doesn't really matter. And, you know, I understand there are some, there are some roles that it feels like it requires you to, okay, for me, every time I work,
I know that I'm going to experience like an ungodly amount of humiliation. It's just, it's just how it's going to go. There's no way that I can get through it without being humiliated. And I think that's part of like letting go in some ways, right? Because it's kind of stupid. Like what we do is stupid.
Yeah. Yeah. And like surrendering to it. It is embarrassing. And like it's really difficult to do some things because if you actually step out for a second and you're like objective and you look at yourself, you just cringe.
So it's so fucking embarrassing and stupid. So sometimes I understand like you have to, I find that I have to like rush right into it and just go like, just humiliate me right now, make me feel like nothing. And so that I'm willing to do this thing. Because if I really think about it, I'll just be so embarrassed that I won't be able to do it.
It's like the stand up comic that goes out there on purpose and tries to bomb, you know, like to sort of rip off the bandaid and just like, I'm up here, I'm exposed, here are the jokes, or here's the non-joke. And that almost becomes a performance of just raw vulnerability and let's all get in it together. I always find incredible. Well, Sean said, Sean, you mentioned like surrender.
There is that moment where you do have to surrender. And I think that you do, like I watch you do all these characters in these movies over the last number of years. And I always, when I think about someone like you, I think like there's a guy who's like sensitive to the material. He's like, I would never want to be like, hey man, how did you do this scene? I'm like, he did a scene, how he did the scene.
You understood the material. You took it in, you were sensitive to it. And then you just like worked with the material that you were given. And that was your interpretation. That was your collaboration with the material, like full stop. Right. And it's also like, you know, journalists, critics, reporters, whatever, just kind of doing just enough of their job
to get you to fill in the blank and so, you know, with no thought behind it. I can't stand that. So how did you lose the weight for Joker? Here he comes. Here he comes. What about, do you remember your, when you were growing up, you guys lived a very sort of atypical adolescence,
like I did as well. How much of it do you remember? Do you remember what the policy was in your house about? Well, devices didn't exist back then, but TV and, or was it the kind of house where go outside, find a rock, find a stick and entertain yourself like it kind of was in my house? Yeah, I don't think we really had a TV until, you know,
until it was probably 11 or 12 or something. I don't know, maybe a bit younger maybe because we'd been working by then, but certainly when I was very young, I don't think there was even a TV in the house, but we did, there were five of us, right? So it's easy to entertain yourself when there's five kids, right? Same.
And my dad was always really amazing at finding houses to rent that were always like, you know, in LA, you can live like we grew up in the valley for a lot, and there's houses that are like by government land, right? There's just like mountain ranges, right? Like that's the backyards, so suddenly you could go there. And so that's what we enjoy doing, right? Just playing games and using our imagination.
So that's what I remember. And now, a word from our sponsor. Hey, listener, SmartList is brought to you by BetterHelp. Now, getting to know yourself can be a lifelong process, especially because we're always growing. We're always changing. And I'm not just talking about your ear size, your nose size, your nose hair, your head hair, or your foot size.
You know, my feet are getting wider and longer. How about that? Anyway, your brain also changes, and so does your heart. So to have an opportunity to process all this stuff literally at arm's length is incredibly helpful. Therapy is all about deepening your self-awareness and understanding because sometimes we don't know what we want or why we react the way that we do until we talk through things.
So BetterHelp connects you with a licensed therapist who can take you on that journey of self-discovery from wherever you are. And every time I've talked to somebody who has processed something, they're excited to tell me about what they've discovered, the new clarity that they have. You're just, you're lighter, and now you're ready to enjoy life or even just that hour a little bit more, right?
So if you're thinking of starting therapy, give BetterHelp a try. It's entirely online, designed to be convenient, flexible, suited to your schedule, just fill out a brief questionnaire to get matched with a licensed therapist and switch therapist at any time for no additional charge. Discover your potential with BetterHelp. Visit betterhelp.com slash smartlist today to get 10% off your first month.
That's BetterHelp, H-E-L-P, dot com slash smartlist. Smartlist is supported by GameTime. Now, I have had very stressful moments trying to get tickets to a sporting event, concert. I'm just, I do everything last minute, and that is not something you want to do last minute. GameTime helps you with that. Buying tickets to your favorite events should not be stressful.
GameTime's the fast and easy way to buy tickets for all sports, music, comedy, theater near you. Killer deals on last-minute tickets and their best price guarantee. You can stop stressing over the tickets and start getting hyped for the fun you're gonna have. I mean, you know, we're right here, we're coming up on summer, and I just know there's gonna be a ton of great concerts
that I'm gonna kind of waffle on, where should I go, should I not go, and at the very last minute, I'm gonna finally either find someone to go with me or get the okay to go, and then I'm gonna try to get, and the seats are gonna be like weird, or who are these weird people that I gotta buy them from, and these, GameTime just eliminates, it helps dummies like me, okay?
So if you're a dummy like me, GameTime's for you, right? Is that a great sell or what? GameTime is the fastest growing ticketing app in the country for a reason. Get images of the seat before you buy, so you know exactly what to expect when you arrive. Buy tickets in a matter of seconds. Two taps, that's it, you're set.
Tickets are sent directly to your phone, so you never even have to dig through your emails. Anyway, listen, snag the tickets without the stress with GameTime. Download the GameTime app, create an account, and use code SMARTLESS for $20 off your first purchase. Terms apply, again, create an account, and redeem code SMARTLESS for $20 off.
Download GameTime today. Last-minute tickets, lowest price, guaranteed. I would like to just send out a quick thank you to ZipRecruiter for their support. Did you know that they support this show? Well, now you do. Now, I'm trying to somehow figure out a way to book somebody famous on this show.
You know, like, I wouldn't mind shooting for the stars. Maybe, like, how about, like, get the president of the United... No, we got him. Oh, how about, like, somebody from the Beatles got Poma Cartney? Well, anyway, if maybe if we're looking for somebody that you maybe you've never heard of but is super interesting,
yes, some place like ZipRecruiter could probably do that for us because they can get anything, anytime, anywhere to help your business, right? They can really help your staff up, and we need some guest staffing help here, so I'm going to give them a little ringy-dingy when I'm done with this ad.
It is very hard to turn down a personal invitation, so just imagine if you are hiring, or in my case, trying to book a show, you could send a personal invitation to the top candidates for your job. That would be great, right? Now you can, with ZipRecruiter's Invite to Apply feature. Right now, you can try ZipRecruiter for free
at ziprecruiter.com slash smartlist. How does ZipRecruiter's Invite to Apply feature work? Here comes the info. First, ZipRecruiter's technology finds and sends you the most qualified candidates for your job. Then, you can review this curated list and invite the ones that you're really interested in to apply to your job at the click of a button.
What could be easier? When you send out personal invites to your favorite candidates, it lets them know that they're one of your top choices, and they'll be more likely to apply. Makes sense, right? Invite ZipRecruiter to be your hiring platform. Four out of five employers who post on ZipRecruiter get a quality candidate within the first day.
See for yourself. Go to this exclusive web address. Get ready to try ZipRecruiter for free. Here comes ziprecruiter.com slash smartlist. Again, that's ziprecruiter.com slash S-M-A-R-T-L-E-S. ZipRecruiter, the smartest way to hire. And now, back to the show. Forgive me, I don't know, Joaquin.
Were you, so you mentioned growing up in the valley. So were you born in L.A., like that was... No, born in Puerto Rico. Oh, that was true. Yeah, I was born in Puerto Rico. Oh, really? That was true. Yeah, let's see.
I think first we lived in... When we came to the station in Puerto Rico, we were in Florida. And then my mother was college roommates with Penny Marshall. Oh, Penny Marshall, yeah. Oh, wow, really? Yeah, and Laverne and Shirley was very popular at the time. And my brother and sister, my older brother and sister, River and Rain, would...
My brother learned to play guitar very young. And they would perform at talent shows and stuff. And they were winning these talent shows. Yeah. So I think they felt like this, like, just this curiosity and natural progression towards, like, something in the entertainment field. My parents didn't really have a lot of experience with it, right?
So I don't think they really knew, but I think that it seemed that the kids had... I don't know, I don't really want to say talent, but whatever the fuck it was, right? Yeah, yeah, yeah. Something, some kind of, like, creative spark. And I think they wanted to support that. And so my mom actually reached out to Penny Marshall
and said, we were thinking of coming to Los Angeles and would you meet the kids? And I think she said, don't, don't come out. You can imagine, like, somebody called you, like, from your past, if you went to college, it was like, hey, these kids, we're gonna come out and work when you meet them. And Penny's like, let me stop you there.
Yeah. No way! Please, please don't come out. And I think we packed up the next day. And I went to LA. And, yeah. That's fucking crazy. So what were your parents doing at the time that they're,
like, in, I think you said Florida, like, what was going on? My dad did, like, manual labor. Like, he was like the groundskeeper for this wealthy man. I think it was like a recording producer. I can remember his name. And there was a, us, like a little guest house
on the property where we lived. Wow. And my dad took care of the grounds. And my mom was raising us. And then we went to Los Angeles. My mom started working at NBC for this amazing casting director named Joel Thirm. Joel Thirm, that's right, at NBC.
And she worked there. And my dad took care of us, to care the kids. And we met Joel. By the way, let me stop you there just for one second. So Joel Thirm, for the listener and for you guys, if you guys, Sean, you may have met him, but maybe he was gone by then. But this was the office where when you were going in
to do a network test, which for the listener, that's the last step before you get a series as an actor. And when you get a series, you're employed for years and years. And it's like, when in the lottery, it's a high stakes thing. So that last audition, that last meeting in that office is Joel Thirm's office. So Joaquin's mom was on his desk. She was sitting at the desk right there where you're sitting
waiting, just like dying with anxiety, right before you're supposed to go in there. And it was like, to me, it's carved into my memory. That office, that little, that lobby, that section right there was where most of my anxiety started. So you're saying Joaquin's mom is so massive. No, no. But she was this ray of sunshine.
And every time I'd run into her, we'd have a very nice warm hug and smile. I love that. Yeah, she's... Wait, so Joaquin, so everybody was in it. Everybody was kind of in it or around it, yeah? Yeah. And so we would go and visit and Joel was always just so sweet.
He would just set us up in his office and we would watch. That's probably where I remember really being exposed to TV and shows, TV shows, was in Joel's office because we would watch all the reruns. He had every tape of every MCC show. That's so cool. Wow, that's so cool. And it was just like the best time going there.
And yeah, and I think we tried to do... I think he actually arranged for us to do some recording, like a test to see if we could do a show as a family. It was like trying to do something. Like a partridge family or something. I guess. And yes, he introduced us to Iris Burton, who was the child actor agent.
And the only one that would take all five of us. Because we'd met other agents. It was a package deal. And they'd be like, I'll take those two, I'll take that. She was like, I'll take them all. Wow. Wow, that's so cool. And so your interest in acting didn't really come as much from watching TV
or watching movies because you guys didn't do a ton of that when you were growing up. It kind of came from once you moved to Los Angeles and you started to get this initial exposure to it. Yeah, I mean, I think it just was an extension of the games that we played. My dad was a fucking ham. Yeah. Like he would do these skits all the time.
And again, because we didn't have TV, we just basically did plays. So we would just make up these kind of scenarios and play them out. Play dress up and shit like that. So I think it just was an extension of that. And then being on set, the energy on a set is unmatched. It's incredible, right? There's just like a hundred people that are all like brilliant in their own specific kind of craft.
Yeah. Right? So you've brought people that it's like incredible what everyone does, right? And there's such a, I think everyone in the best case scenario, one's really excited about what they're doing and they work really hard to kind of create this world. And that's a really interesting energy and it's fucking fun as a kid. You know, it's like, it's so exciting to be on a set.
So there was something that was just really enjoyable about it. And then I remember the first scene that we did in this TV show in Southern Brothers, Southern Brothers, and one of the characters, Peter Horton, was the actor. And we'd been friends with them, you know, because we'd been there on set. And so they were in the scene with him. And he's meant to get into a fight with the boyfriend of the woman that played our mother.
And they get in this like fight and they're rolling around the ground. And like to an eight-year-old, shit felt very real, right? And he was like, our friends, we were worried about him. And I remember being like overcome with this emotion of what was happening. And I distinctly remember like, like physically buzzing from it. And it was such a powerful feeling because it wasn't real. It was safe.
然后他们打了起来，在地上滚来滚去。对一个八岁的孩子来说，这感觉太真实了，对吧？他说，我们的朋友，我们都很担心他。我记得当时自己被那种发生的事情的情绪给淹没了。我清楚地记得，甚至能感觉到那种身体上的嗡嗡作响。那种感觉太强烈了，因为这不是真的。它是安全的。
But like, I like had this feeling course through my body. And I was like, I want more of that. It was so fucking exciting. And nothing has ever given me that feeling. Like you're obviously safe because you're doing multiple takes. It's not then the world's a fucking movie, but it can feel so dangerous. You know, you feel like so much pressure because you're committing something and it's going to be around forever.
但这种感觉传遍了我的全身，我就想，我还要这种感觉。这太他妈刺激了。没有什么东西能给我这种感觉。就像你显然是安全的，因为你可以拍好几次。这并不是说世界真的变成了一部电影，但它感觉可以那么危险。你知道，你会感到巨大的压力，因为你在投入某些东西，而它将永远存在。
And there's something that just feels like really exciting about that to me still. That's so interesting. Hey, Joaquin, did you do any comedy? Always funny in what you do. Even if it's a drama, you'll find the comedy. But no, like a pure. Have you ever done like a pure again? Forgive me.
对我来说，那种感觉至今仍然非常令人兴奋。这太有趣了。嘿，华金，你演过喜剧吗？你演什么都很有趣。即使是悲剧，你也能找到喜剧色彩。但不是那种纯粹的……你演过纯粹的喜剧吗？原谅我。
Have you done like a pure, pure comedy? I remember seeing you and to die for it. I thought that was darkly funny. Darkly funny. Yeah. Oh yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Die for it with Nicole.
你演过纯粹的、纯粹的喜剧吗？我记得我看过你演的《不惜一切》。我觉得那部电影带点黑色幽默。黑色幽默。对。哦，对。对，对，对。和妮可一起演的《不惜一切》。
Yep. I love that. That was I think in the 90s, right? Was that a great experience? It was a great experience. Yeah, well, I hadn't the last film that the last acting that I'd done was when I was, I don't know, 14 or 15 in a movie called Parenthood. And then we moved out of Los Angeles.
是的。我喜欢那部。我想那是90年代的吧？那是一段很棒的经历吗？那是一段很棒的经历。是的，好吧，我当时……我拍的上一部电影、从事的上一部表演是在我大概14、15岁的时候，一部叫《为人父母》的电影。然后我们就搬出了洛杉矶。
We moved to Florida. And I basically given up acting. Yeah, I didn't think that I was going to act again. And then I, then I, my brother really encouraged me to start acting again. And he was actually going to make a film and he wanted me to play his, his brother. And I think that kind of sparked my renewed interest in it. And then yet to die for came up. I remember going and auditioning for that.
我们搬到了佛罗里达。我基本上就放弃表演了。是的，我当时觉得我不会再演戏了。然后，然后，我哥哥极力鼓励我重新开始演戏。他当时正准备拍一部电影，想让我演他弟弟。我想这在某种程度上激发了我对演戏的热情。然后《不惜一切》就来了。我记得我去为那部电影试镜。
I read that script and I instantly had an idea of, of what I thought. The character was and went audition for it. And I was always really fortunate. The directors that I worked with, a lot of them just didn't have ego and weren't desperate to like micromanage and control and really encouraged me to, to bring my ideas to it and to, to discover it. I remember it really started with Ron Howard on Parenthood. And I was surprised at how curious he was about my thoughts and feelings about the
我读了那个剧本，立刻就有了我对这个角色的理解，然后就去试镜了。我一直很幸运。我合作过的很多导演都没有什么自我意识（ego），他们并不急于对你进行微观管理和控制，而是极力鼓励我把自己的想法融入其中，去发掘角色。我记得这一切真的是从《为人父母》的朗·霍华德开始的。我很惊讶他对我的想法和感受竟然那么好奇。
character. So I just, I didn't know that that was allowed. And, and Gus was, you know, the same thing where I remember him just saying like, it doesn't, it doesn't matter. Like things don't have to go right. Like whatever happens is a part of it and it's okay. So don't worry about like any kind of rules in some ways. And there's a thing that you learn as a kid that you're supposed to pride yourself on,
角色。所以我当时根本不知道原来这是被允许的。而且，格斯也是这样，我记得他当时就说，没关系，事情不需要按部就班地进行。发生什么都是过程的一部分，这没关系。所以不用担心有什么规则。有些东西你小时候就被教导应该为此感到自豪，
which is like hitting the mark and finding your light and knowing your lines. And I think that all of that stuff is like really dangerous because it just like leads to things being flat. Like when everybody is just like hitting their marks and we know what's going to happen take after take, you just like, it's just human nature. Like inevitably you just follow it, fall onto something being like just wrote. And I think it lacks like an energy and excitement. And we're in this like unique position where you can do multiple takes.
那就是站准位置、找到光位、记住台词。我觉得所有这些东西都非常危险，因为它们只会让事情变得流于表面。当所有人都只是按部就班地站位，而且我们对每一条的走向都心知肚明时，你就会——这只是人性。你不可避免地就会落入某种流于形式的俗套。我觉得这缺乏一种能量和兴奋感。我们处于这种可以拍很多条的独特位置，
So why not take advantage of it and, you know, let it be something different each time within a certain reason. And those are things that I learned from my early experiences. Like it's okay. I think because films are so expensive and there's so many moving parts, we like to try to control it as much as possible. Where do you sit on that? Because I battle with this as an actor and also as a director sometimes about, you know,
所以为什么不好好利用这一点呢？在一定范围内，每次都让它呈现出不同的效果。这些都是我从早期的经历中学到的东西。这没关系。我想因为电影成本太高，涉及的变数太多，我们总是倾向于尽可能地去控制它。你对此怎么看？因为作为一个演员，有时也是作为一个导演，我也会在这方面纠结，你知道的，
how much you should just sort of pay attention to the natural thing of it that you should adhere to the technical specifics of that particular shot. For instance, let's say the camera angle is really tight on you and you're sitting down and in the middle of the line, you have to stand up. And because you're in a real tight shot, the cameraman asks you to stand up kind of slowly. Don't shoot up because if you shoot up, I lose you in the camera. Again, I can't keep up with you. And so they ask you to kind of come up with sometimes they call it a groucho.
你究竟应该在多大程度上顺其自然，又该在多大程度上严格遵守特定镜头的技术细节。举个例子，比如说镜头离你很近，你正坐着，在台词说到一半时，你必须站起来。由于镜头推得很紧，摄像师要求你慢慢站起来。不要猛地一下站起来，因为如果你猛地站起来，镜头就会把你拍丢。再说一遍，我跟不上你的节奏。所以他们会要求你用一种类似格鲁乔·马克思（Groucho）式的姿态起来。
You kind of come up kind of slow like in a hunch. But certain actors, myself, sometimes I'll be like, well, no, I got to shoot up because I'm pissed off. Like, so either widen your shot or just anticipate. How much do you, like, are there times when you're a little bit more cooperative with that than other times? I mean, I find myself in that sometimes I just, I can't do it as a director. Sometimes I'll hesitate and even asking an actor to do it. But the shot might be, might really need it. Where do you sit with all that stuff?
你得稍微弓着身子慢慢站起来。但有些我自己这样的演员有时会觉得，不，我得猛地站起来，因为我很生气。所以要么你把镜头拉宽，要么你就得提前预判。在多大程度上，比如，有没有那么一些时候，你会比其他时候更愿意配合这些要求？我是说，我自己有时也会遇到这种情况，作为导演，我真的做不到。有时我在要求演员这么做时也会犹豫。但这个镜头可能确实需要这样做。对于这一切，你是怎么看的？
The combination between the technical and the natural in what you do? I guess it depends. I mean, every film is different. There's not really one way of approaching it. And there are times where I think it makes sense that the other night we were shooting and camera was behind me. And I was moving towards the other actor. And just from years of doing it, I knew to, like, widen out a little bit to, like, favor the right side so that it was clear on them. And I remember as I was doing it, I was so ashamed that I hated myself so much.
在你的表演中，技术性和自然性是如何结合的？我猜这得看情况。我是说，每部电影都不一样。并没有一种固定的处理方式。有时候我觉得这样做是有道理的，前天晚上我们在拍戏，摄像机在我身后。我正朝着另一个演员走去。出于多年的演艺经验，我知道应该稍微走宽一点，倾向于右侧，这样他们能拍得更清楚。我记得当时我一边这么做，一边感到无比羞愧，我太讨厌自己了。
And I was like, this means that I'm not in the fucking moment because I'm aware that camera's there. And then afterwards they were like, can you widen out a little bit? I was like, oh, I thought I was already widening out as much as I was comfortable with. And I was fucking embarrassed. And now you ask me to do it more. It's kind of our job though, isn't it? I mean, it's not part of it though, right? When you're doing theater, right, Sean?
我就想，这意味着我根本没有完全投入到当下，因为我知道摄像机就在那里。然后拍完后他们说，你能再往外走一点吗？我说，哦，我已经按我能接受的最大幅度往外走了。我当时尴尬极了。现在你们还要我再多走一点。不过这算是我们的工作，对吧？我是说，这难道不是其中的一部分吗？当你演戏剧的时候，对吧，肖恩？
You don't have to accommodate the other part of the process, which is the camera or the lighting or something. Like when we're doing movies or television, that is part of it. And I feel bad for pushing back on that as an actor. Like, my performance needs to stay pure and I don't even want to know about the camera. Yeah, but at every point of it, it is. Like if you're doing this show, Sean, I imagine, like you're always thinking about don't upstage, make sure, right? Yeah, all the time, you always play out. You have to play out.
你就不需要去适应流程中的其他部分，比如摄像机、灯光之类的东西。但当我们拍电影或电视剧时，这就是其中的一部分。每当我作为演员对此产生抵触情绪时，我都会觉得很内疚。比如，我的表演需要保持纯粹，我甚至都不想去管摄像机在哪。是的，但在每一个环节里，它确实就是这样。如果你在演这部剧，肖恩，我想象你肯定也一直在考虑别抢戏，确保……对吧？对，一直都在，你总是得照顾到全局。你必须照顾到观众。
And also there's faces staring at you. But it's distracting, right, Joaquin? Like it knocks you out of it. You've got this big monologue as Oscar Levant and that you're doing this moment at the same time you're thinking like, fuck, can everybody hear me in the back row? I'm sure you have those moments, right? Yeah, yeah, for sure. Yeah, it's terrifying. But Joaquin, it distracts you out of the performance though, yes?
而且还有一堆脸盯着你看。但这很让人分心，对吧，华金？就像把你从情境中拉出来一样。你在饰演奥斯卡·列凡特时有一段长长的独白，你一边在做这个表演，一边心里还在想，操，最后一排的人都能听见我说话吗？我敢肯定你也有过这种时刻，对吧？对，对，肯定的。对，太吓人了。但华金，这确实会把你的注意力从表演中分散出来，对吗？
Well, I think the job is to be as true to the moment as possible. And sometimes that's easier than other times for whatever reason. Sometimes I watch like basketball players and it's just like going in for them. And other times it seems like they're really working at it and focusing. It's just one of those things. Like sometimes you're in the flow and there's nothing. Those are the best moments when somebody can be making noise off camera talking and you're not distracted by it. You could throw anything at you and you're just in it because you're just in the flow.
嗯，我觉得我的工作就是尽可能地忠于当下。由于种种原因，有时这很简单，有时则不然。有时候我看着篮球运动员，感觉他们状态来了，势不可挡。而其他时候，看起来他们真的在苦苦挣扎和专注。事情就是这样。有时候你进入了心流状态，外界的一切都不复存在。那些才是最好的时刻，当有人在镜头外制造噪音说话时，你也不会被分散注意力。你可以把任何东西砸向他们，而他们依然沉浸其中，因为他们进入了心流状态。
And then there's other times where it's a bit more difficult. It feels like it's so artificial, everything that's happening. And I guess the job in some ways is to try to make it feel as organic as possible. And sometimes that's easier than other times. So I think if you're in it and you're in one of those moments, it's like, yeah, I can make that adjustment. It's not getting in the way. And there's other times where you go like, no, you have to adjust the camera because I can't do this. I don't really know why that happens.
但也有一些时候，情况要困难得多。感觉发生的一切都太不真实了。我想某种程度上，这份工作就是要努力让它感觉尽可能地有机自然。有时这很容易，有时很难。所以我想，如果你正全身心投入其中，处于那种状态下，就会觉得：是的，我可以做出调整。这并不妨碍我。但也有其他时候，你会觉得：不行，你们得调整摄像机，因为我没法这么演。我其实也不知道为什么会这样。
It's that level. It's that thing you started talking about, about that level of discomfort and embarrassment of like, I have to kind of commit to this thing and to really commit to it is kind of embarrassing. It's just weird as shit and you're making that hard for me. But yeah. Yeah, that's what I want to talk about because all, you know, what I'm doing in this play is a big swing for the fences. It's like, this is embarrassing as all, all hell. Like I'm playing somebody that's nothing like me at all.
就是那种程度。就是你刚才谈到的那种不适感和尴尬感，比如：我必须全身心投入到这件事中，而真正全身心投入其实挺尴尬的。这他妈太诡异了，而你们却在给我制造困难。不过，是的。是的，这正是我想要讨论的，因为你知道的，我在这个话剧里所做的一切，是一次巨大的冒险。这感觉他妈的尴尬透顶。我扮演的是一个跟我毫无相似之处的人。
Yeah. And then, and then I see Joaquin play, do that over and over again. I'm like, gosh, how in the world do you get past that feeling of, you know, humility. Of leaving yourself so fully. Yeah, like over and over and over again. It's just kind of fascinating. I wonder if is the director, I would imagine is a big, big part of it, right? I mean, you've worked with so many incredible directors that so clearly have, pardon the term, a vision and clear, you know, leadership.
对。然后，然后我看到华金一遍又一遍地做这种事。我就想，天哪，你到底是怎么克服那种谦卑感的？那种毫无保留地展现自我的感觉。对，就像是一遍又一遍地重复。这实在太迷人了。我在想，导演应该在其中扮演了很大很重要的角色吧，对吧？我是说，你合作过那么多出色的导演，他们显然都拥有——原谅我借用这个词——一种远见和清晰的，你知道的，领导力。
No, I'm not going to pardon the term. I'm not going to fucking do it. But is that, is that a big, big part of it for you when you're considering what to do next? Is it, is it, is it as much about the director as it is about the part or is it, is it more so? I mean, the director is it. Yeah. It's kind of that, that simple, right? Because everything ultimately runs through them.
不，我不会原谅这个词。我他妈才不干。但对你来说，当你在考虑下一步该接什么戏时，这难道不是一个非常、非常重要的因素吗？比起角色本身，导演是不是同样重要，甚至更重要？我是说，导演就是一切。对。就是这么简单，对吧？因为一切最终都要通过他们来呈现。
Yeah. Even if they, they're choosing the cinematographer and the editor, everyone that they're working with, they're ultimately saying yes or no to which take is being used. Right. Especially because, you know, I, I like to, to do, to approach each take differently. Sometimes there's a lot of choices that the director has. And so you have to really trust them that they're going to make the right choices because sometimes I will, will do things that may not be right for the scene. And I'll, I'll, I'll know that. I'll know that this is probably not the right approach for the scene. But I'll do it partially just to, just to change things up, just to put me in this place where I don't really know what's going to happen. It suddenly just opens it up, the possibilities.
是的。即使他们选择摄影师和剪辑师，他们合作的每一个人，最终都是由他们来决定采纳哪一个镜头。特别是，你知道的，我喜欢以不同的方式来处理每一个镜头。有时候导演会有很多种选择。所以你必须真正信任他们，相信他们会做出正确的选择，因为有时我会做一些可能并不适合这个场面的事情。而我自己心里也很清楚。我知道这可能不是处理这场戏的正确方法。但我这么做，部分原因只是为了打破常规，把我置于一个连我自己都不知道会发生什么的境地。这突然之间就打开了局面，带来了无限的可能。
And there are times you go, fuck, I hope they don't use that one. Right. Or if they use a little piece of that with, with one that's, with a take that's more sort of norm, then it makes you look like a shit actor. So you really have to trust the, the ingredients that the director's going to use downstream when he's cooking things together or she. Yeah. Or it made you look like a genius. Yeah. Yeah, exactly.
有时候你会想：操，希望他们别用这一条。或者，如果他们把其中的一小部分剪进那条更常规的表演里，就会让你看起来像个烂演员。所以你真的必须信任导演在后期制作时会使用的那些原材料。或者这会让你看起来像个天才。对，对，正是如此。
So you use a little piece of something and, and you're like, oh, that was actually from an earlier part in the scene. That wasn't even my reaction for that line. Right. But that's like, that's great editing. So yeah, the filmmakers, everything. Yeah. You're so reliant on the taste of a director. Todd Phillips certainly has it in spades and you're, you're, you're the film that's coming out right now.
所以他们用了某个片段的一小部分，然后你会想：哦，其实那是这场戏前半部分的表演。那甚至都不是我对那句台词的真实反应。没错。但这就是伟大的剪辑。所以，是的，电影制作人就是一切。是的。你太依赖导演的品味了。托德·菲利普斯在这方面绝对是行家里手，而你——你即将上映的那部电影……
Well, Ari Aster, he seems like a guy is just, just overflowing with genius. That trailer is stunning. I can't wait to see that film. This is called Bo is afraid. Bo was afraid. How was making that because for, for, for the listener, it's, if you haven't seen the trailer, it's a correct me if I'm wrong. You're walking it. It's about a guy going to see his mom and the, the sort of the, the fear and sort of dreamscape or nightmare escape inside of his head as he approaches that event is where this film kind of takes us.
还有阿里·艾斯特（Ari Aster），他看起来就是一个才华横溢到要溢出来的人。那个预告片太惊艳了。我等不及要看那部电影了。这部电影叫《博很恐惧》。《博很恐惧》。拍摄这部电影的感受如何？因为对听众来说，如果你还没看过预告片，我没说错吧，华金？讲的是一个男人去探望他的母亲，在接近那个事件的过程中，他脑海中那种恐惧以及梦境般的、噩梦般的场景构成了这部电影的主旨。
Is that a shitty enough explanation of it? Yeah, sounds good. That's just what I gathered from the trailer. But it's so, so it's very sort of fantastical and I don't know. I love sort of Spike Jon stuff and Charlie Kaufman stuff. And this seems in that, in that world and just another great example of that type of filmmaking. I'm so excited to see it. Did you love doing it?
我这个解释够烂的吗？对，听起来挺好。这正是我从预告片里感受到的。但它非常具有奇幻色彩，而且我不知道。我很喜欢斯派克·琼斯和查理·考夫曼的作品，这部电影似乎也属于那个世界，又是这种类型电影的另一个伟大范例。我太兴奋想看了。你喜欢拍这部电影吗？
I did love doing it. I have just great admiration for Ari and his, his approach and you're very early on, I realized like how perceptive and observant he was. And sometimes there are some scenes where you think like, okay, well, I can get away with it. Like, I can, I have no choice, but I have to act through this, right? Because this would be very difficult to maintain this for like six hours. Right. So inevitably there's gonna be a wide shot and I'm going to be acting in this one at the, at the end of the day, you know, and that happens if you once wanted something you really want to avoid. And it's horrible, but sometimes you're just so fucking tired and you can't do it. And again, the voice creeps in just going, this is stupid. What are you doing? Stop taking this seriously.
我确实很喜欢。我对阿里以及他的创作方法只有满满的敬佩。很早的时候我就意识到他是多么具有敏锐度和观察力。有时有些场景你会觉得：好吧，我可以蒙混过关。比如，我别无选择，我只能硬着头皮演过去，对吧？因为要连续六小时保持这种状态实在太难了。没错。所以不可避免地会有一个全景镜头，而到了一天结束的时候，我还得在这个镜头里演，你知道的。如果你想极力避免某件事，这种情况偏偏就会发生。这太糟糕了，但有时你实在太累了，根本做不到。这时候那个声音又悄悄爬上心头：这太蠢了。你在干什么？别把这当回事了。
Yeah. Go home. Yeah. And so you have to fight that voice off, but it's very difficult if, if the filmmaker has that same voice and is also going like, hey, let's just come on and wrap this up. And I knew very early on that Ari was not that filmmaker. Right. And so I think that we, we were just constantly pushing each other to, to commit to it. Yeah.
对，回家吧。对。所以你必须跟那个声音作斗争，但如果电影制作者也有同样的想法，也在说：嘿，咱们赶紧收工吧，那就很难办了。我从一开始就知道阿里不是那种导演。没错。所以我觉得我们一直在互相推着对方去全身心地投入。是的。
As, as much as possible. And so there was no, there was no kind of like, oh, let's, let's cheat in this wide shot. We did one wide shot that was like, it's so ridiculously wide. And it's such a brief moment, but I had to like, I wanted to like collapse in the take. And I couldn't just like, drop to my knees. I just was like, this is just ridiculous. It felt like two melodramatic or something. Drop to my knees. And, and it was, and it was, it's stupid looking back on it. I was like, I could have just dropped my knees and nobody would have known the difference. But I, I just, I just felt like I was, I was cheating if I, if I did that. Wow.
尽可能地投入。所以没有什么——没有什么所谓的“哦，咱们在这个全景里偷懒作弊吧”。我们拍过一个全景镜头，那个镜头广角拉得太离谱了。那是一个非常短暂的瞬间，但在那个镜头里我必须——我想在镜头里崩溃倒下。我不能只是顺势跪倒在地。我当时就觉得：这太荒谬了。感觉有点太戏剧化了。直接跪在地上，回想起来觉得挺蠢的。我当时想：我本来可以直接跪在地上，没人能看出区别。但我——我只是觉得，如果我那么做了，就是在作弊。哇。
I love how honest you are about that. By the way, Jason, you asked him the question, like, how was it making? And then you like took a moment to really, so often people are like, yeah, it was great. No, he's all honesty. I love it. No, it's fucking great. And it reminds me, Sean, how many late nights have you been like, we're not, it's getting too late and you just got to drop your knees. I mean, it's gotta be. I don't need a reason. I don't need the motivation. It gets me to sleep early. And we will be right back.
我很喜欢你对此的坦诚。顺便说一句，杰森，你问他拍摄感受如何，然后你留出了一点时间去真正……通常人们都会说：“哦，挺好的。”不，他全盘托出，我太喜欢了。不，这他妈太棒了。这让我想起了肖恩，你有多少次在深夜说：我们不……时间太晚了，你只能直接跪下。我是说，肯定有这种时候。我不需要理由。我不需要动力。这能让我早点睡觉。我们马上回来。
SmartList happens to be supported by FanDuel. Did you know that? Grand Slam's no hitters and double plays are back, y'all. And there's no better place to get in on the MLB action than FanDuel. America's number one sports book. That's because right now new customers can step up to the plate with a no sweat first bet up to $1,000. Just go to FanDuel.com slash SmartList, sign up, place your first bet and get up to $1,000 back in bonus bets if you don't win. Now, some of the ways you can use these bonus bets, you could, well, you could bet on maybe the over under on how long Sean's play is going to stay open on Broadway.
《SmartLess》由FanDuel赞助播出。你知道吗？大满贯、无安打比赛和双杀又回来了，各位。要想参与美国职业棒球大联盟（MLB）的博彩活动，没有比美国第一大体育博彩公司FanDuel更好的地方了。那是因为现在新用户只需进行最高1000美元的无风险首注，即可大展身手。只需访问FanDuel.com/SmartLess，注册，下注你的第一笔赌注，如果不赢，即可获得最高1000美元的免费下注返还。现在，你可以用这些免费下注做的一些事情包括，嗯，你可以赌一下肖恩的话剧能在百老汇上演多久的大小盘。
I would take the over, but I know the smart bet would be the under. No, that's not true. That's not true. I hear it's incredible. It's why it's on Broadway because it did so well in Chicago. So take the over. Now, what you can take the under on is how long will is going to fill in the blank. I was going to say something hurtful, but I'll let you do that right in your own hurtful mind. So don't miss your chance to get a no sweat first bet up to $1,000 when you join FanDuel today.
我会买大盘，但我知道明智的选择是买小盘。不，这不是真的。这不是真的。我听说这棒极了。这就是为什么它能在百老汇上演，因为它在芝加哥大获成功。所以买大盘吧。现在，你可以买小盘的是威尔会在空白处填什么。我本想说点伤人的话，但我还是让你在自己那颗满怀恶意的心里去说吧。所以，当你今天加入FanDuel时，千万不要错过获得高达1000美元无风险首注的机会。
Just go to FanDuel.com slash SmartList to sign up FanDuel, official partner of Major League Baseball 21 plus exclusions apply. See show notes for full disclaimer. Scammers are best known for living the high life, globetrotting on private jets, dining at five star restaurants and driving six figure sports cars. That is until their house of cards collapses and they're forced to trade it all in for handcuffs and an orange jumpsuit. Scamfluencers is a podcast from Wondery hosted by Sarah Hagi and Sachi Cole that tells the unbelievable true stories behind some of the world's most infamous scams, swindlers and con artists. Scamfluencers has covered jaw dropping scandals from Ponzi schemes to a fake Saudi prince to a sexual predator masquerading as a wholesome yoga guru. These scammers cost their victims hundreds of millions of dollars and immeasurable emotional anguish. So how does our culture allow them to thrive?
只需访问FanDuel.com/SmartLess即可注册。FanDuel是美国职业棒球大联盟官方合作伙伴。21岁以上，特定条款适用。详情请参阅节目说明。骗子们最出名的就是过着穷奢极欲的生活，坐着私人飞机环游世界，在五星级餐厅用餐，开着六位数的跑字豪车。直到他们的纸牌屋轰然倒塌，被迫用手铐和橘色囚服换掉这一切。《骗子大腕》（Scamfluencers）是由Wondery出品、Sarah Hagi和Sachi Cole主持的一档播客，讲述了世界上一些最声名狼藉的骗局、诈骗犯和江湖骗子背后难以置信的真实故事。《骗子大腕》涵盖了令人瞠目结舌的丑闻，从庞氏骗局到假沙特王子，再到伪装成健康瑜伽大师的性掠夺者。这些骗子让受害者损失了数亿美元和无法估量的精神痛苦。那么，我们的文化是如何让他们蓬勃发展的呢？
Each story on scamfluencers will take you along the twists and turns, the impact on victims and what's left when the facade falls away. Follow scamfluencers wherever you get your podcasts. You can listen ad free on the Amazon music or Wondery app. And now back to the show. Well, I was just thinking about years ago, I remember when Amy, my ex-wife was still on SNL and you came. I remember you came to SNL and you were shooting. You were with Casey Affleck and you guys were shooting. I'm still here.
《骗子大腕》中的每一个故事都会带你领略其中的曲折离奇、对受害者的影响，以及当虚伪的面具剥落后留下了什么。在各大播客平台订阅《骗子大腕》。你还可以在亚马逊音乐（Amazon Music）或Wondery应用上收听无广告版。现在，回到我们的节目中。嗯，我刚才在想几年前，我记得当我的前妻艾米还在《周六夜现场》（SNL）的时候，你来了。我记得你去了《周六夜现场》，当时你在拍片。你和卡西·阿弗莱克一起拍片。我还在。
Yeah. Yeah. So talk to me a little bit about that, man. Yeah, I was actually thinking about that today. I don't know why I was remembering actually being going to SNL because there was an actor that I ran into in the hallway and I can't remember who it was or I just don't want to say. And I was kind of like doing my shit for that movie. And she's somebody that I worked with and she's very shocked and concerned. And I remember like to look on her face, I so desperately wanted to tell her like, it's okay.
对。对。所以跟我聊聊那个吧，伙计。对，我今天其实还在想这事。我不知道为什么我突然想起去《周六夜现场》的事，因为我在走廊里遇到了一位演员，我不记得是谁了，或者我只是不想说。我当时正在为那部电影做我的那些疯狂行径。她是我合作过的一个演员，她显得非常震惊和关切。我记得看着她的表情，我当时多么渴望告诉她：没事的。
She's a thing. So we like made this commitment that we weren't going to tell anybody that it wasn't real. So listener, this thing that he's talking about, I'm still here. This was a documentary about Joaquin quitting acting and becoming a rap star. Wait, I want to hear Joaquin tell it. Well, write that in a nutshell. Everybody thought it was real. I have no reason to think it wasn't real and everyone was trying to be very...
这是一场戏。所以我们当时立下誓言，绝不告诉任何人这不是真的。所以听众朋友们，他说的这件事，就是《我还在》。这是一部关于华金退出演艺圈去当说唱歌手的纪录片。等等，我想听华金自己讲。好吧，简而言之。所有人都以为那是真的。我没有理由认为这不是真的，每个人都表现得非常……
Except that I was like 35 saying I'm retiring from acting to be a rapper. But that's what made it so electric is because everyone wanted to be really sensitive to, oh my God, what a tragic mistake this young actor is making. I can just tell you that at SNL that night that I was there, you were there. It was like late 2008, I think. I think Archie had just been born and you were like... And I remember you were walking in and you guys were shooting stuff and then I forget where the band was. And you guys came down onto the floor on 8H and you guys were shooting it. And I remember everybody in the cast was like, what's going on?
除了我当时35岁，却说我要退出演艺圈去当说唱歌手。但正是这一点让它变得如此具有电气般的张力，因为每个人都想对“天啊，这个年轻的演员正在犯多么悲惨的错误”保持高度的敏感。我只能告诉你，那晚我在现场的《周六夜现场》，你也在。那是2008年底吧，我想。阿奇好像刚刚出生，而你当时……我记得你走进来，你们在拍东西，然后我忘了乐队在哪里。你们来到了8H演播室的地板上，在那里拍摄。我记得演员阵容里的每个人都在问：这到底是怎么回事？
What is he... What is happening? Like nobody knew it was... Like you really had everybody... The train wreck is coming through. Fooled and like, yeah. But you know, it wasn't to fool other people like what we discovered is like... The moment somebody knew what was going on that it wasn't real, I became terrible.
他在干什么？这到底发生了什么？根本没人知道这是……你们真的是把所有人都……火车正在脱轨。给骗了，而且，是的。但你知道，这并不是为了愚弄其他人，我们发现的是——一旦有人知道了到底是怎么回事，知道这不是真的，我的表演就变得糟糕透顶了。
Like I started being like really hammy and like winking at the camera. And I think the whole trip was to try to get it to feel as real as possible. And so the only way that it felt real was when other people believed it was happening. And it forced me to try to play it as believably as possible. And so that's why we just didn't want to tell anybody because the moment... Because there were some friends that... Like actor friends that I would do some scenes with. And they, because they knew me so well, they figured it out.
比如我开始变得非常浮夸，对着镜头挤眉弄眼。我觉得整个恶作剧的秘诀就在于，要尽量让它感觉尽可能真实。而它感觉真实的唯一方法，就是当其他人真的相信它正在发生的时候。这迫使我不得不尽最大可能去演得令人信服。这就是为什么我们谁也不告诉，因为一旦……因为有些朋友——比如一些演员朋友，我会和他们拍一些对手戏。而他们因为太了解我了，所以看穿了。
And I would inevitably just really start overdoing it. Just really kind of hamming it up. And so we just discovered like very early on that when I... If somebody thought that it was real, it just made me embarrassed and scared. And then I would just kind of be more internal with it and I think more believable. So then just don't tell anyone, right? Yeah. And it was awkward and uncomfortable. And this girl, this actress that was there, she emailed me.
而我不可避免地就会开始演得过火。开始变得非常浮夸。所以我们很早就发现，当我在——如果有人以为那是真的，这反而会让我感到尴尬和害怕。然后我就会把这种情绪更多地内化，我觉得这样就更可信了。所以干脆谁也别告诉，对吧？对。而且这既尴尬又别扭。当时在场的这个女孩，这个女演员，她给我发了邮件。
Like a couple of these later. And she just said like, I know what you're doing. And I actually was so relieved. So relieved because I was so embarrassed. Did you respond? Did you confirm? I did not. I did not. Yeah. By the way, I tried to do this thing with this guy Bob, this writer yesterday on set.
过了好几年后。她只是说：我知道你在干什么。我当时真的如释重负。如释重负，因为我太尴尬了。你回复了吗？你确认了吗？我没有。我没有。顺便说一句，昨天在片场，我试着对这个叫鲍勃的编剧做过类似的事。
And we were like, it's April Fools and we're like, and I don't do April Fools. But I was like, he was like, just pretend to fire me in front of the crew. And I was like, okay. And then so we got later in the day and I'd sort of forgotten about it. And then he walked out and then we started this argument and it got really awkward. But I had to commit to it because in the middle of it, I'm like, fuck. And it felt so like sort of status wise. I felt shitty.
我们当时在想今天是愚人节，我们就想——我不怎么过愚人节。但我就说，他说：你就假装在剧组所有人面前解雇我吧。我说：行。然后到了那天晚些时候，我差不多把这事给忘了。接着他走了出来，我们开始争吵，气氛变得非常尴尬。但我必须硬着头皮演下去，因为在争吵过程中，我在想：操。而且从某种地位的权力感来说。我觉得自己像个混蛋。
Like an asshole. Yeah. And I hated that feeling. And I was like, why don't you get the fuck out? Well, why do you even bother showing up? If you're going to just pitch me shitty jokes and get the fuck. And I started going like that. Anyway, we sort of got to the end of it and I finally said April Fools after a few minutes
像个白痴。是的。我讨厌那种感觉。我就说：你他妈的怎么不滚蛋？你既然要给我出那些烂主意，那就给我滚。我开始这么冲他嚷嚷。不管怎样，我们差不多吵到了尾声，几分钟后我终于说出了“愚人节快乐”。
and the fucking crew, it got really quiet and it wasn't fun. No. And it made them all feel like comfortable. It fucking sucked. Wait, how did that all end up? I don't remember how that all finished up. When did the curtain come down on all of that? Was it on the release of it or?
然后剧组里——气氛变得死一般寂静，一点都不好玩。没有。这让他们所有人都感到很不自在。糟透了。等等，那最后是怎么收场的？我不记得最后是怎么收尾的了。这出戏是什么时候落幕的？是在电影上映的时候吗？
Yeah, on the release. And at that point, we'd been shooting for like two years, I think, or a year and a half or something. And I was, I had been so looking forward to this moment of saying like it wasn't real. Because it had just been so uncomfortable. And I just had avoided so many friends because I just didn't know how to kind of like keep up the rules. And then so I can't remember how we kind of, you know, released it and said, oh, it wasn't real. Nobody believed us. They suddenly thought like, oh, yeah, of course, now after you fucked your career,
对，在上映的时候。那时候，我们大概已经拍了两年，或者一年半左右。我一直非常期待说出“这不是真的”那一刻的到来。因为这实在太让人难受了。我躲开了好多的朋友，因为我根本不知道该怎么继续遵守这个规则。然后我不记得我们是怎么，你知道的，把它发布出去并宣布：哦，这不是真的。结果根本没人信我们。他们突然觉得：哦，对啊，当然了，现在你把自己的职业生涯毁了，
you're trying to say that this is like this spoof. Oh, they thought you like had regrets and come back. Oh, my God. No way. And so I was like, oh, fucking can't, can't win. Can't win over. But then you showed them what was up, what you came back with the master, right? Wasn't that, wasn't that what followed?
你才想说这其实是个恶搞。哦，他们以为你后悔了，然后又复出了。哦，天哪。不会吧。所以我想：哦，操，真是赢不了。怎么都赢不了。但后来你用杰作证明了自己，不是吗？紧接着上映的不就是那部作品吗？
Well, that was, yeah, I mean, the thing is, is that as a product of this, of this, of I'm still here. I think at that point, a lot of people that maybe would consider hiring me were like, even if it's not real, you have to be kind of fucking nuts to do this. So he's probably, probably not something you want to work with anyways. And I remember my, my options. A PTA was like, bring it on. Yeah, my options at the time were just left a lot to be desired in terms of work. And I remember really at one point just really being desperate and feeling like,
嗯，那是，是的。我是说，问题在于，作为《我还在》的后续产品。我觉得当时很多本来可能会考虑雇佣我的人会觉得：就算这不是真的，你也得他妈的够疯才会干这种事。所以他可能、可能无论如何也不是个好合作的对象。我记得我的选择。PTA（保罗·托马斯·安德森）当时的态度是：放马过来。是的，我当时的职业选择在工作方面确实差强人意。我记得有那么一刻，我真的感到非常绝望，觉得自己
well, I actually really fucked myself and I can't, I can't get a job. And I was really considering doing this, this movie that was a terrible movie. I knew it was terrible, but I was like, I just have to get back and show people that this wasn't fucking real. No fucking way. And I almost did it. And actually my agent, Boomer, who was actually, he was the assistant of my original agent, Patrick Weitzel. And he'd started working with me. At first I was like, oh, fucking bait and switch.
真是把自己给坑惨了，根本接不到工作。我当时甚至真的在考虑去拍一部烂片。我知道那是部烂片，但我想：我必须回去向大家证明这不是他妈的假的。绝对不行。我差点就接了。实际上，我的经纪人布默（Boomer）——他其实是我原经纪人帕特里克·韦茨尔（Patrick Weitzel）的助理。他开始跟我合作。起初我还想：哦，操，挂羊头卖狗肉。
Like I'm working with your assistant now, this is bullshit. And then I remember talking to Boomer and I was saying, look, man, I'm just, I'm lost. I'm desperate. It's the first time in my life like I don't feel like I know what, what to do. And I'm asking for advice. I've never done that. You know, I always really have a strong sense of like what I want to do. And he was like, do you have to do this movie?
我现在居然在跟你的助理合作，这太扯了。然后我记得跟布默谈话时，我对他说：听着，伙计，我迷茫了。我很绝望。这是我生平第一次感觉自己不知道该怎么办了。我在向你寻求建议。我以前从没这么做过。你知道的，我对自己想做什么一向有着强烈的主张。而他却说：你非得拍这部电影吗？
I said, what do you mean? He goes, does it matter to you? And I was like, no. He goes, well, then why are you doing it? And I really needed that at that moment. I just, I felt so fucking lost and confused. And it was really, it was a really important moment for me. And so I said no to the movie.
我说：你什么意思？他说：这对你很重要吗？我说：不重要。他说：那你在拍个什么劲？我当时真的很需要那句话。我感觉自己太他妈迷茫和混乱了。那对我来说真的是一个非常重要的时刻。所以我拒绝了那部电影。
And then a couple of months later, Amanda Demi reached out to me and she said, hey, Paul's trying to get in touch with you. No way. And he sent the script over. I remember looking, you know, through the script and there was Freddie and Master. And I was like halfway through and I was like, there was no way he's calling me for one of those parts. You know, so I called him. I said, what, what character am I supposed to read? Because I figured it was like something that pops up, you know, for a couple of scenes.
然后几个月后，保罗·托马斯·安德森联系了我，他说：嘿，保罗想联系你。不会吧。他把剧本寄了过来。我记得我翻看着剧本，里面有弗莱迪和大师。我看到一半的时候心想：他绝对不可能找我演这些角色中的任何一个。你知道的。所以我给他打电话。我说：我到底是去试读哪个角色的？因为我觉得那大概是个只出现几个场景的龙套角色。
And he was like Freddie. And I didn't even finish the script and I had to prevent myself from saying like, yes, right there. So I was halfway through and I was like, just fuck. Yeah. I couldn't believe that he wanted me for that. That's so cool. Well, that's, that's, before we let you go, I want to ask you just real quickly about Napoleon. And it's one of the movies I'm looking most forward to seeing coming up. It seems like that was a really robust shoot.
而他说：弗莱迪。我甚至还没读完剧本，就得极力克制自己当场答应下来的冲动。所以我看到一半的时候就想：操。是的。我简直不敢相信他想让我演那个角色。太酷了。好吧，在让你离开之前，我只想简单问你一下关于《拿破仑》的事。这是我最期待上映的电影之一。看起来那是一场非常宏大的拍摄。
I mean, period and Ridley Scott and that subject matter. I mean, was it as epic as it sounds like? What can you tell us about that, if anything? Yeah, it was, it was a fucking massive production. The amazing thing about Ridley is he's like overseeing this massive machine. Like just like hundreds of extras, eight cameras, you know, these huge locations. And he can just pivot like, like that. Like he could arrive on on set and make a discovery in the moment and feel like the scene is maybe leading in like a new direction.
我是说，历史题材、雷德利·斯科特以及那个宏大的主题。我是说，它真的像听起来那么史诗感十足吗？关于这部电影，如果可以透露的话，你能告诉我们什么？是的，这绝对是一部他妈的巨制。雷德利最神奇的地方在于，他就像在统领一台巨大的机器。就像有成百上千的群演、八台摄像机，你知道的，还有这些巨大的外景地。而他可以瞬间扭转乾坤。比如他到达片场，当场灵机一动，发现场景可能会走向一个新的方向。
And he's just fine. Like he will adjust, he will adjust the camera, he will adjust to the performance. Like if there's something that feels honest and real and like a worthwhile exploration. Turn a steamer ship around. And it's so impressive to me. Because yeah, I mean, I don't know how much we were spending a day, but it was, it was a lot. And I had a great experience with him, you know, all those years ago on Gladiator. And so I just was always, always wanted to work with him again. That's so cool.
而他完全没问题。他会调整摄像机，他会根据演员的表演做出调整。如果有什么东西感觉真诚、真实，并且值得去探索。他能把一艘大轮船调转方向。这对我来说太震撼了。因为，我是说，我不知道我们一天的花销是多少，但那绝对是个天文数字。多年前在《角斗士》剧组时，我和他有过一次非常棒的合作，所以我一直、一直都想再次和他合作。太酷了。
You know, I know we're going to let you go because you're going to get back. But, you know, hearing you talk, I've never met you. I know you probably hate this, but I'm a huge fan of yours. And you are an inspiration to me and tons of other actors. So much respect for you. I know you hate that because it feels false, but it's not. But you're married, you have a baby boy of purpose with animal rights activism. You have a great career.
我知道我们得放你走了，因为你得回去。但是，听你聊天——我从没见过你。我知道你可能讨厌这样，但我真的是你的超级粉丝。你对我以及成千上万的演员来说都是一种激励。我对你充满敬意。我知道你讨厌这种恭维，因为它听起来不真实，但这是真心话。不过你已经结婚了，你有一个可爱的儿子，有着投身动物权益保护事业的目标。你有着伟大的事业。
You have all this stuff going on in your life. Are you able to sit back and just kind of absorb all that? Or do you have a defense mechanism where you're just like, no, I got to, I just, I know everything's great. I just got to keep going. I just got to keep going to challenge myself the next thing. Or can you really sit back and absorb all the great things that have happened to you? As you get older, it all becomes easier. I'm fully cognizant of what a charmed life I have.
你的生活中发生了这么多事情。你能够坐下来好好消化这一切吗？还是说你有一种防御机制，让你觉得：不，我必须——我知道一切都很好，我只是得继续前进。我只是得继续前行，在下一件事上挑战自己。还是说你真的能坐下来，好好感受发生在你身上的所有美好事物？随着年龄的增长，这一切都变得容易了。我完全清楚自己过着怎样备受眷顾的生活。
It has exceeded my expectations or my greatest dreams. I'm so fucking grateful for what I have, the family and friends that I have and the opportunity for work. I never imagined it would be like this and it has been so fulfilling. So I really do appreciate it and value the opportunity that I've had. But I just want more experiences. I just love making films. I love collaborating with people. It's just so exciting to talk about makeup and hair.
它超出了我的预期，甚至超过了我最伟大的梦想。我无比感激我所拥有的这一切、我的家人和朋友，以及工作机会。我从未想象过生活会是这个样子，而且它是如此充实。所以我真的很感激并珍惜我所拥有的机会。但我只是想要更多的经历。我就是喜欢拍电影。我喜欢和人们合作。讨论妆发是一件多么令人兴奋的事。
You're sitting around with all these people that are really good at what they do. You get to kind of create something together. It's just an incredible opportunity. I love that you said that. You said it before when you were talking about all the people on set. I don't think people appreciate enough. I love that you said it. Everybody on set, no matter what their job is, everybody is a filmmaker.
你和所有这些在各自领域极其优秀的人坐在一起。你们一起创造出一些东西。这真是一个不可思议的机会。我太喜欢你刚才说的那番话了。你之前谈到片场所有人时也说过类似的话。我觉得人们对这一点还不够感恩。我太喜欢你说的了。片场每一个人，无论他们的工作是什么，每个人都是电影制作人。
Everybody is part of the process in that way. Too often, you see people who don't spend the time of the energy. Every single person here is making this film together. There's nobody there that doesn't have to be there. It's something a lot of people don't realize. Walk your incredible at it. Please keep going. We'll take twice as much.
每个人都是这个过程的一部分。很多时候，你会看到有些人并没有付出时间和精力。这里的每一个人都在齐心协力完成这部电影。这里没有一个是不必要存在的人。这是很多人都没有意识到的。华金，你在这方面太棒了。请继续保持。我们恨不得看双倍的量。
But I know you got a kid to raise and Rooney to hang out with. She's awesome too. She found us our dog. She found us our dog, Gary. He's a real cutie. We love you and thank you. Say hi to Todd and Larry. Have a great day of work.
但我知道你还要抚养孩子，还要陪鲁妮。她也很棒。她帮我们找到了我们的狗。她帮我们找到了我们的狗，加里。它真是个小可爱。我们爱你，谢谢你。代我向托德和拉里问好。祝你今天工作愉快。
I hope this has been okay. It's been awesome. Before you go, how do you get into Joker? We ended up talking about the process and nobody got hurt. No, but in a good way. Thank you for taking the time. Very nice to do this, buddy. Thank you guys.
希望刚才的谈话还算顺利。棒极了。在你走之前，你是怎么进入《小丑》的状态的？我们最后聊到了表演过程，而且没有人受伤。没有，不过是以一种好的方式。谢谢你抽出时间。能做这个访谈太棒了，伙计。谢谢你们。
Honestly, this was painless. Painless. Kind of. When you're done, hurry home and we'll talk some more. Okay, great. Thank you all so much. Have a good day. Bye walk.
老实说，这过程一点都不痛苦。不痛苦。算是吧。等你忙完，赶快回家，我们再多聊聊。好的，太棒了。非常感谢大家。祝你们过得愉快。再见，华金。
Man. Amazing. That's an artist. This is an actor. Did you know him, Jason, for a long time? Yes. We don't spend every day with one another by any stretch, but we've known each other for a long time.
天哪。太惊艳了。这才是艺术家。这才是演员。你认识他很久了吗，杰森？是的。虽然我们并没有天天腻在一起，但我们认识很久了。
We've got some very close mutual friends. He's a guy I would love to talk further with, deeply with, at length with, but as you can tell, he doesn't really enjoy talking about the stuff that we're all fascinated with about him. And that's probably why he's so goddamn good at what he does. Maybe he just doesn't care to look at how the magic trick is done. It's something he's great at.
我们有一些非常要好的共同朋友。他是一个我很想跟他深入、广泛、详尽地聊聊的人，但正如你所见，他其实并不太喜欢谈论我们大家对他那种着迷的东西。这可能就是他为什么能把这行干得这么该死的好。也许他根本不在乎去研究魔术是怎么变出来的。这是他非常擅长的事。
It's something that he enjoys. That's what I was getting at. I forgive those people for talking about the process, but I meant more about the people who go out of their way. They're like, look at my process. It's so difficult what I do. That's what I meant. When they offer it first.
这是他喜欢的事。这就是我想表达的意思。我原谅那些谈论过程的人，但我的意思是那些特意跑出来的人。他们就像是，看我的过程。我做的事多难啊。这就是我的意思。当他们主动提起的时候。
Yeah, when they offer it first and they're like, my whole thing, my whole identity is wrapped around how I do it. And I want everybody to know and to think that, and be impressed by my process, which he is like, there couldn't be further removed from that. He's like, man, I don't want to tell you anything. He's also one of those actors I love watching and trying to understand what that character must be thinking.
对，当他们主动提起，然后觉得，我的全部，我的整个身份都围绕着我是怎么做到的。而且我想让所有人都知道并这么想，对我的过程留下深刻印象，而他完全不是这样。他就像是，老天，我什么都不想告诉你。他也是我最喜欢看的演员之一，总是忍不住想去猜那个角色当时在想什么。
He's a very internal actor. And you kind of, if I knew what he was thinking, and I knew how he was doing it, or if I knew that much about him, if he did a bunch of press and all that stuff, it'd be hard for me to buy him being somebody else. So I kind of liked that he's mysterious. When you watch him do like,
他是一个非常内敛的演员。你会觉得，如果我知道他在想什么，知道他是怎么做到的，或者如果我对他的了解有那么多，如果他做了大量宣传之类的，我就很难相信他是另一个人。所以我其实挺喜欢他的神秘感。当你看着他演类似……
I was thinking the last thing I saw him in was Joker, and you watch him in that performance. Amazing. Yeah, incredible. And, you know, millions of people love it. Some people don't. Whatever you think that when you watch him, he's so compelling, Jason, like you say,
我在想我最后看他的作品是《小丑》，你看着他在里面的表演。太棒了。对，难以置信。而且，你知道，数百万人都喜欢它。有些人不喜欢。不管你怎么想，当你看着他时，他是如此引人入胜，杰森，正如你所说，
because you're like, what is he? He's so inhabiting it in those moments. And he has these moments where he take, and you're watching and you're thinking like exactly that. What is he thinking? How is he, where is he now? Where it says he's more into the work than all the other stuff.
因为你会觉得，他是什么？他在那些时刻完全融入其中。他有一些时刻，你在看着，心里想的正是这个。他在想什么？他是怎么，他现在在哪？这说明他更专注于工作本身，而不是其他那些乱七八糟的事。
But he's also, I don't know. I mean, if... It sounds so fucking accurate to say, but... He manages to do something that I love when I watch actors is their ability to communicate vulnerability and humanness and flaws and elements of being broken because we're all broken. We're all vulnerable,
但他也，我不知道。我是说……说这话听起来他妈的太准确了，但是……他设法做到了一点，这也是我看着演员时最喜欢的一点，那就是他们能够传达出脆弱、人性、缺陷以及破碎的元素，因为我们都是破碎的。我们都是脆弱的，
but we all learn these different, you know, skins of trying to like hide it. And he is so courageous. Just as a person who was talking about making a fool out of himself, of being kind of warts and all, like look at all my flaws, and he finds those in every character because that's all part of it, I suppose,
但我们都学会了各种不同的，你知道的，试图将其隐藏起来的外壳。而他是如此勇敢。作为一个敢于出丑、敢于展现缺点、甚至说看我所有的缺点的人，我猜他在每个角色身上都能找到这些东西，因为这都是其中的一部分，
is just being not fully put together, you know, with his characters. He's only the second, but he is only the second guest we've had who is Killing Sigs during the interview. Oh yeah, Sean Penn was the other one, right? Yeah. Killing Sigs. You haven't smoked yet during an interview, have you?
就是他的角色并不是完全完美无瑕的，你知道的。他不仅是第二位，而且他是我们采访过的第二个在访谈期间抽烟的嘉宾。哦对，西恩·潘是另一个，对吧？对。抽烟。你在采访时还没抽过烟吧，对吗？
No, I did when I was in London, remember? I was recording from London. I did a couple of times. So that was, what was that called if you smoke a cigarette over there? Oh, crushing. It's not crushing, but it's crushing. Don't say it.
没有，我在伦敦的时候抽过，记得吗？我是从伦敦连线录制的。我抽过好几次。那是什么，那边管抽烟叫什么来着？哦，crushing。不是 crushing，但是是 crushing。别说出来。
Don't say it. We'll have to lift it. We know what you're going to say. Jesus, Sean. Don't say it. I was just curious. I don't know what it's called. Sean, you're trying to bait him into a cancellation.
别说出来。我们得把它剪掉。我们知道你要说什么。天哪，西恩。别说出来。我只是好奇。我不知道那叫什么。西恩，你这是在故意引诱他被封杀啊。
Are you looking to recast? You're looking for a new third? No, you can crush some facts over here. Oh, she says, Sean, for fuck's sake, what is wrong with you? Well, I'm talking about, what would the term be, what would the term be, though, speaking of which, if you liked men and you liked women? Yeah.
你是在物色新演员吗？你在找第三个新搭档？不，你可以在这里抽几根烟。哦，她说，西恩，看在上帝的份上，你到底怎么了？好吧，我在说，那叫什么词，话又说回来，如果你既喜欢男人又喜欢女人？对。
That makes you... Oh, that would be bye. Guys. We haven't done just a straight up bye yet. Oh, I know. Smart. Right. Smart.
那会让你……哦，那就是双。双性恋。我们还没做过纯粹的双性恋呢。哦，我懂。聪明。对。聪明。
Smart. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Bennett Barbicot, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Amjarf. SmartLess. Our next episode will be out in a week, wherever you listen to podcasts, or you can listen to it right now, early on Amazon Music,
SmartLess 由 Bennett Barbicot、Michael Grant Terry 和 Rob Amjarf 100% 有机手工制作。SmartLess。我们的下一期节目将在的一周后发布，你可以在任何收听播客的地方收听，或者现在就在亚马逊音乐上提前收听，
or early and add free by subscribing to Wondery Plus in Apple Podcasts or the Wondery app. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
或者通过在苹果播客或 Wondery 应用上订阅 Wondery Plus 来提前收听且无广告。这期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。